[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTOINE SAKHO: Busuu is one of
the world's leading language
learning apps.
Our mission is to empower
everyone in the world
to learn a new language.
The way we do this
is by providing
our users with high
quality courses
designed in-house
enriched by conversations
with native speakers.
The whole idea being
that to learn a language,
you need to practice it with
people who actually speak it.
That's really what people
love about our product,
is this social interaction.
To date, over 65
million people have
used Busuu to learn a language.
And interestingly, out
of our five largest
markets on Android, four
are emerging countries--
namely Turkey, Russia,
Brazil, and India.
What we've come to realize is
that a lot of emerging markets
have limited storage, memory,
they have slow or intermittent
connectivity, so we've started
doing more to really empathize
with those users.
EDOARDO TOGNONI: The Network
Log was the first tool
that we used.
With that, we were
able to reduce
the amount of data
we were exchanging,
because we were able to
tackle some bugs in our code.
The memory profiler is
another tool that we use.
With that, we were
able to make sure that
what's inside the memory
is what is meant to be
and nothing more.
Since we are a language
learning application
and we support different
interface languages,
Lint is a great tool for us.
With Lint, we're
able to make sure
that we have 100% of the
data complete and correct.
When we were focusing
on performances,
one thing that we saw is
the database was huge.
So we decide, OK, lets
get rid of the database.
Let's go online.
We were able to reduce the APK
size from 60 megabytes to 25
megabytes.
That was a huge
improvement for us,
and we saw a lot more downloads
from emerging markets.
ANTOINE SAKHO: Following
our work on performance,
we've seen our weekly average
ratings jump from 4.1 to 4.5,
which is the highest
we've ever had.
EDOARDO TOGNONI:
Every developer has
to make sure that
their own app is
working in every type of device
in every type of environment.
Having more tools that are
focused on performances
for sure will have and will
make developer's life easier.
ANTOINE SAKHO: Performance
is not something
that you set aside
and forget about.
It's something you
have to instill
in the culture of the business.
[MUSIC PLAYING]